ils essaient de nous détruire tous de
nous effacer de la surface de la Terre
les mots du président ukrainien après
les bombardements russes les plus
intenses depuis des mois en Ukraine en
déplacement en Mayenne le président
français a exprimé son inquiétude on va
voir
au téléphone très longuement je tiendrai
une réunion dès mon retour de Mayenne
j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer dans un
cadre approprié évidemment la France a
eu le j'ai eu l'occasion de le faire ce
matin à condamné avec la plus grande
fermeté les frappes délibérées de la
Russie sur l'ensemble du territoire
ukrainien et contre des civils ce qui
est un changement profond de la nature
de ça Emmanuel Macron promet d’accroître
l'aide militaire de la France à
l'Ukraine tout comme Berlin qui a
réitéré la solidarité de l'Allemagne et
les autres États du G7 à Kiev
l'Allemagne fera tout pour mobiliser une
aide supplémentaire et en particulier
pour aider à réparer et restaurer les
infrastructures civiles endommagées et
détruites telles que l'approvisionnement
en électricité et en chaleur
message de soutien également de la part
de Londres qui dénonce des bombardements
inacceptables des frappes barbares pour
l'Union européenne
la Russie opte pour une tactique
consistant à viser et à bombarder les
civils
c'est quelque chose qui va à l'encontre
du droit international humanitaire et ce
ciblage de civils équivaut un crime de
guerre
l'OTAN condamné aussi des attaques
horribles et aveugles et assurer de son
soutien aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
une réunion virtuelle du G7 aura lieu
mardi avec volody mirzelenski sur la
situation en Ukraine
et qu'en est-il des